تسير في شوارع العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
الان
مظاهره نحو 200 الى 300 شخص يرددون
شعارات تطالب بوقف لاطلاق
النار تردد شعارات فلسطين حره وتدعو
للحريه
لفلسطين
وقف الفصل العنصري وانهاء الفصل العنصري
في فلسطين
هه المهت خرجت وبشكل متكرر ومتزايد ضو
شعبيه في شت الولايات الامريكيه هنا في
واشنطن رايناها خارج البيت الابيض خارج
الكونجرس الخارجيه الامريكيه كان هناك
اغلاق لشوارع رئيسيه في ولايات كبيره يعني
تظاهرات متعدده لممارسه ضغط شعبي اليوم
هذه المظاهره هنا في واشنطن في شتى انحاء
المدينه ليست موجهه ضد هيئه او جهه حكوميه
راينا حتى الناس في الشوارع يتفاعلون مع
المتظاهرين في بعض الاحيان من الشرفات
بالتصفيق هذه المظاهرات ساهمت بضغط كبير
على المشرعين الامريكيين ليزداد عدد
المشرعين المطالبين من الديمقراطيين بوقف
فوريا لاطلاق النار سمعنا تغيير في لهجه
حتى من من لا يطالبون بوقف اطلاق النار
ولكن يتحدثون على ضروره وضع شروط على
الدعم الامر
الوي المح لاسرائيل بان هذا الدعم يجب ان
يتماشى مع القيم الامريكيه ومن الشعارات
التي نسمعها دائما بانه يجب ان لا تساهم
الاموال التي يدفعها دافع الضرائب
الامريكي في اله وعمليه القتل في قطاع غزه
وهذه الحرب المستمره التي ادت الى قتل
الالاف من
المدنيين بكويك الجزيره
واشنطن